WAS THE SEASON FINALE LAST YEAR
AGAINST THEHE GRANLUND.
VETERAN GROUP ON THE POWER PLAY
COME WITH THE EXTRA ATAT
IN BEHIND THE NET, HERE ON THE .
HE COMES UP THEN COMES BACK DOWN
SOUTH.IN FACT, GREENWAY PROBABL
PLAYED HIS BEST GAME OF THE ON
SIDE AND FABBRO CHASED BY
RASK.
DUCHENE NOW WITHTH BUT YOU GET
HIGH REWARD WHEN YOU TAKE 1-4-3
LAST EIGHT HEAD TO HEAD.ROSS FO.
DUMBA FIRES, SAVE INGRAM,
CHEMISTRY.
NEXT THING YOU KNOW, HE'S
GETTING THE PUCK ON HIS TAPE AN.
NICE PLAY.
D ZONE BREAKOUT, JVE ZONE
FACE-OFF, SO IT COULD BE A QUICK
THREE,
MATTER OF TIME FEEL TO IT FROM
THE START.
GRANLUND DROPS ITT ON TWO
EX
DUCHENE WITH A NICEKAPRIZOV.
PUTS ON THE BRAKES ALONG THE
FLATFOOTED.
PREDATORS GET TWO ON ONE BJUGST
WHERE HE CAN SHOOT IT QUICKLY.
FIRESA.
THEY ALL SEEMED LIKE NO AS HE S
FROM POINT GET TO THE POST
BEFORE KAPRIZOV.E TRIED
TO FIRE FROM THE TOP OF THE
CIRCLE.
BRODIN BRINGS IT OFF.
AND THE CROWD OBVIOUSLY A DIFFET
TROOP SEATTLE AND THEN STOP IN
DENVER FOR A DIVISIOIO